cloud computing is one of the fastest
growing fields in technology
and that growth is only accelerating as
more companies shift to remote work
according to mckinsey surveys companies
currently have around 50 percent of all
workloads running on public
and private cloud platform by 2022
that share is projected to rise to 75
percent
several cloud providers are benefiting
from that rapid growth
microsoft azure is being used by 95
percent of fortune 500 companies
and burning glass projects that growth
in azure related jobs
is expected to hit over 38 over the next
decade
to stay ahead of the curve in the
programming world you'll need to
understand
how to harness the power of cloud
development
with udacity's new cloud developer using
microsoft azure nanodegree program
we've partnered with microsoft to
deliver you a hands-on experience with a
variety of cloud computing principles
and best practices
using azure's development portal you'll
learn how to deploy an article content
management system to microsoft azure
implement serverless microservice
backend architectures
strategically migrate a conference
registration system to azure and collect
and analyze data about the health and
performance of an application
this nanodegree program offers an ideal
path for software and web developers
looking to future-proof their career
with cutting-edge high-growth
technologies
enroll in udacity's cloud developer
using microsoft azure nanodegree program
today